MALE SPEAKER: Today we
have for Talks at Google
the man behind the label, Scott
Jordan, the founder and CEO
of SCOTTeVEST clothing.
So you may have seen his apparel
in the Google Store or online
or even on my person where I
now have 23 pockets on my person
right now, which is super
handy, super useful.
Scott's here today to talk to
us about his new book, which
is called "Pocket Man."
It's the story of really
SCOTTeVEST from his early days
to becoming a lawyer to
working at SCOTTeVEST
full time to "Shark
Tank" to the present day.
So he's going to give us
some thoughts on his journey,
and then we'll have some time
for questions at the end.
You can also find Scott's
book on scottevest.com
and the Amazon
Kindle store as well.
So please join me in
welcoming him to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT JORDAN: Thank you
so much for having me.
I really do appreciate it.
I'm a huge fan of
Google, and it's
a real honor to be here today.
I have to tell you.
I'm going to be just
perfectly honest.
This is my first
speech for the book,
so if I'm a little rough around
the edges, please work with me.
My team came up with
all these cards,
and I'm just going
to talk freely.
I do so much better just
talking off the cuff.
So if there's something
I say during this speech
that you have a question on,
just please interrupt me.
Raise your hand.
Ask me about that, because
you might forget at the end.
And it's about my journey
in starting SCOTTeVEST
and what it means.
How many of you guys are
familiar with SCOTTeVEST
before you got the email?
Yay.
Awesome.
I see some customers here.
So, the book is about the art of
passionate personal promotion.
Because when I sat down and I
reflected on writing this book,
I thought, well, what
do I have to say?
And it's hard because I've
been at this now for 14 years.
When I founded
SCOTTeVEST in 2000,
little did I know I was
starting the first apparel
brand on the internet.
Before then, no apparel brands
had started on the internet.
And I'm not through living
life and accomplishing things,
so I was like, well, what am I
going to write this book about?
What makes me truly unique?
And I talked to people
that I was working with,
my friends, my
family, and they said
one thing that always comes
through when they talk to me
is my passion.
I'm really passionate
about what I do,
so the book is about my
passion and my journey.
And first and foremost,
if you read this book,
you will be entertained.
I promise you that.
It is an entertaining journey.
Because I did not want
to write a book that
was going to be like,
this is how I did it,
steps one, two, three.
If you just follow-- I'm
just telling a story.
It's the story of my life.
I was a miserable lawyer, and
I hated it, and I thought,
wow, I'm looking for
pockets in things,
and I'm in a business
casual environment.
And I came up with this concept
of something 14 years later
it still seems that sample.
Put more better
pockets in clothing.
Everyone loves pockets.
So that's the basis
of my company.
And how I've gone about
selling an idea so simple
is with my passion.
So I'm actually, now,
I'm traveling around
in this crazy car,
the Polaris Slingshot,
which I've decorated.
Are you guys familiar with it?
You've seen it?
It's actually parked
right in front.
It's actually a motorcycle,
and it has no top.
And I left Sun Valley,
Idaho, about a week
and a half ago in
minus 11 degree weather
and drove down to
Las Vegas at CES
and had an opportunity
to hang out.
Everyone wanted a ride.
I'm taking Guy Kawasaki
and Robert Scovill
and a variety of other
people, and there's
tons of media devoted to that.
So I found a way to get people
to stand in front of the car
and do this what we call the
power pocket man pose and take
pictures, and they
posted to the internet.
So it's a great experience.
I made my way to LA, and
now I'm in San Francisco.
I'm actually going to leave
it with Robert Scovill,
and we're having a pimp my
Polaris contest where we're
going to try to get
suggestions of what
cool stuff to put in the car.
We're going to do some
live streams and stuff,
and then I'm going to take
it back to Sun Valley.
So, I did mention it
was minus 11 degrees
when I left Sun Valley in
that car and it has no top.
And I was really fortunate.
I don't know if you know the
famous photographer Thomas
Hawk, but I had an opportunity
to hang out with him yesterday
and we shot the car.
And it was a great
experience, and there's
a bunch of those
pictures online.
So, I firmly
believe that showing
is much better than
talking, although I
do talk quite a bit for
those of you who know me.
So first and foremost,
for those of you
who don't know
SCOTTeVEST, I am wearing
one of our SCOTTeVEST
products, actually not just
one but three.
It all started out as a vest and
therefore the name SCOTTeVEST,
and it's grown into
a company with more
than 40 different products
ranging from pants to shirts
to jackets, winter jackets
and still the vest,
women's clothing and the like.
We've been in Inc's Fastest
Growing Company list
now three years in a row,
and we do this all out
of beautiful Sun Valley.
Idaho.
So I'm going to show you what's
in my pockets and the reason
why I came up with this concept
of designing a SCOTTeVEST.
Well, first and
foremost, I came up
with this idea of patenting the
concept of wires in clothing,
because one thing
happened to me.
It's probably happened
to a lot of you.
It was pre-iPod days.
I had a Discman.
I'm listening to music.
I got wires dangling
all over me.
I'm in an airport and
I walk by a doorknob,
and it practically
pulls off my ear.
Literally, I grabbed the thing.
I expected to see
my earlobe on it.
So I said, there's
got to be a better way
to design clothing that
incorporates a method
to wire your devices.
So I came up with this idea of
incorporating headphone wires,
but not just headphone
wires but also for batteries
as well because you want to
keep your devices charged
at all time.
And wiring it and routing
it through clothing,
I filed for a patent
and I got the patent,
reissued the patent.
I actually went on "Shark
Tank" to present that company.
There's a whole back story
to "Shark Tank" if any of you
have seen that episode.
It was highly controversial.
And I actually spent
the first several years
of the company just thinking,
OK, all I want to do
is clip coupons.
I came up with an invention.
I just wanted license
to other companies.
I don't want to make anything.
I just want to collect checks.
Well, what I found is in the
apparel business especially,
no one wants to
license a patent.
They don't believe in patents.
So I figured, especially the
patent wasn't even issued.
So I had a patent pending, and
I started SCOTTeVEST merely
as a proof of
concept back in 2000.
And a funny thing happened.
SCOTTeVEST became
wildly successful
due to what I was doing,
passionate personal promoting,
because I did not want to
practice law ever again.
So I took every opportunity
to get out and talk to people.
You can find me on
blogs back in 2000 just
interacting with people
trying to get them.
So without further ado, we have
a pocket here for my cell phone
that you can actually
see and control right
through the fabric,
get your calls
without taking your phone
out, and it's really cool.
So that's my iPhone 6.
And the wires, it can be
wired up right through here
through this
patented this system.
I have an iPad mini.
And that will fit the
full-size iPad too.
I have a passport here
and safe and secure.
We actually have a
guarantee offering.
If you're ever pick
pocketed, we'll
reimburse you up to $1,000.
Because we know no one's going
to reach into that pocket.
No claims on it, but
I get to promote it.
So, this pocket actually
on the newer garments
we've lined with RFID
blocking material.
I think that one.
No, it's not?
Yeah.
So, to me it's always
about batteries,
so I've got an extra
battery, an extra cord.
I've got a Bluetooth headset.
And this I just grabbed.
I got some suntan lotion.
I got gloves.
I got a GoPro that hopefully
didn't break when it fell.
I got a key holder.
Guys are always
forgetting their keys,
and that was part
of the frustration
and how I started SCOTTeVEST.
I was always asking my
wife where I'd put stuff.
And she said, why don't
you just create something?
That was the moment that
SCOTTeVEST was formed.
I have to feel all the pockets
to make sure I got them all.
I have another battery because
without batteries I'm screwed.
I've got a charger.
So, I could go on.
Let me just empty out.
I have a 2 terabyte disk.
I've got something to
clean my eyeglasses.
And I got--
AUDIENCE: Is it heavy though?
SCOTT JORDAN: No.
That's a great question.
And I've got a radar detector.
Because what we've done is--
and I'm going to take it off
because it's a
little warm in here--
we've designed this
so that the weight
resides on your shoulders.
So we've engineered.
We've taken a completely
different approach to clothing.
I mean, I really feel like
I've reinvented pockets.
And you think
about it, clothing,
when they designed
pockets, they weren't
thinking about what goes in it.
And that little pocket that
Levi's have, who uses that?
So in my pants
pockets, I've got this
for the microphone
all the way down here.
I keep my wallet down
here and around back.
I've got layers of
pockets, and yet they
look like-- the concept
is design clothing that
first and foremost
looks good, but design
pockets so that you can
carry all your stuff.
This pocket is actually one
of my favorites in this shirt
and one of the hardest
ones to-- because it's
a design for my iPhone 6.
We engineer clothing
with fulcrums and design.
We really engineer clothing
so it doesn't rub up
against you uncomfortably.
You can't make it disappear.
It's a big unit, but it
enables you to carry it.
And then how many
guys are sitting down
and you're always
sitting on your wallet?
Well, we just moved
it down a little lower
so that it's down here.
So that's the basis for
SCOTTeVEST and the clothing.
Now, my story is
really about my passion
and just going around and being
in opportunities like this.
I never turn down an opportunity
to talk about my product,
never ever.
And using the
internet, it's enabled
me to view the
world differently,
and I've done this
from the beginning.
I send video messages because
passion doesn't come through
in an email.
It never can.
In fact, passion in an email
can often be read as anger.
And passion, there's a very fine
line between passion and anger
anyway as it can be
possibly perceived,
because I get really
excited about something.
Scott, why are you so angry?
I'm not angry.
I'm just really
excited about it.
So what I've done
for a very long time
is I use tools, mailVU
and various other things.
I send email messages of videos.
So, I convey my
message through videos,
even if it's a short message.
And by doing so, it enables
people to really get
a sense as to who I am
and what my message is.
And on my website itself,
if you look at it,
there's a lot of video.
There's a lot of me.
Any of you are old enough
to watch "The Brady Bunch."
I'm looking around and
several of you are,
so you remember Sam the butcher?
You go in.
You buy some steak from Sam.
You know him.
He's not going to be your
best friend, but you know him.
You feel comfortable
giving him your money.
Well, my premise
is that if people
feel comfortable
that they know Scott.
They can send me an email.
They can engage with me on
Facebook or any of the other.
That's my primary channel.
I would encourage you
guys all if not friend me
because I'm very
prolific, follow me
and choose and pick and choose.
And be forewarned, you start
pressing like too much,
you're going to get deep in.
I'm going to
overwhelm your feed.
But it's interesting stuff.
So basically the
premise is create
these personal relationships
and let my passion come through
in an authentic way, completely
unscripted as the cards will
indicate.
But passion is one thing,
but without the drive
to follow through--
I have a philosophy.
I run my business on two
letters, FU-- Follow Up.
Every single email
I get I follow up
on until it comes to a natural
conclusion or it's dead.
So I have a drive.
I never have an
idea-- and I have
tons-- that I'm not willing
to write down and do.
And that's why we are able
to create a business doing
about $12 million with 15
people in Sun Valley, Idaho,
because we are just
using technology
to find a way to constantly
implement everything
that we come up with.
And we've been able to do it.
But you don't want to be just
around a passionate person
who's just talking about
all these great things
and never doing anything.
That's boring.
There's an expression
in "Ferris Bueller,"
one of my favorite quotes.
In "Ferris Bueller" he
goes-- the movie of course--
"Life moves pretty fast.
If you don't stop
and look around,
you're going to miss it."
And my take on that expression
is, life moves pretty fast.
If you stop and look
around, you might miss it.
So I'm just moving
really fast in everything
that I do, and it's
with a lot of drive.
So, this is obvious.
All these messages
are in the book.
Like I said, it's not like,
Chapter 1, these top four steps
in order to achieve success.
I read this and I look.
Yeah, no shit.
You do shit.
You just constantly do stuff.
If you look at what I've
done in the past week,
it's been a whirlwind.
I bought this car,
just by way of example.
I got it three weeks ago.
I got it scanned.
I recognized it.
Hey, here's this vehicle,
has no compartments in it
at all, no trunk at all.
I'm going to go to CES.
I'm going to put my logo on it.
I just generated the Pocket Man
logo just in time for the book,
which, by the way, we wrote
in six weeks beginning to end.
It was literally
published eight weeks
after we had our
first meeting on it.
And that's not to say it's not
a good book, because it is.
And if it isn't, write about it.
Go look at Amazon reviews.
Those are all authentic reviews.
So, I got the car, and I
said, I'm going to Vegas.
And my PR firm
sucked, and I just
decided I'm just going
to drive around and offer
really notable people
rides in the car.
And I sit in the car,
and it occurred to me,
how am I going to
create content that
is going to get out
there and get more people
to know about my brand?
Because we don't have
multimillion-dollar budgets
for advertising.
Most of our advertising,
we spend a minuscule amount
on advertising.
It's PR is what we've done.
So I get them to
ride in the car.
I say, I'm going to
ask you one question
at the end of the ride.
They're like, fine.
Take me for a ride.
So I take them for a ride.
What's your passion?
That's the question.
And I'm learning so
much about people
and what makes people successful
and how people can perhaps
find their passion.
And it's really been a
fascinating experience.
My premise is, for me,
when I was practicing law
at a very major law firm,
DLA Piper, the largest law,
I was miserable.
At the end of every day,
I had to somehow find
eight hours that were worth
writing down at $300 an hour
that were worthy
of being billable,
and it was just excruciating.
My premise is,
you can find a job
or do what you're passionate
about and tie it to your work.
You can be exceptionally
successful and happy as well.
And I think I've
done that, and I
think there's a
template for that.
And I think more and
more people can do that.
And I see it all the time.
My maid, for
example, how can you
be passionate
about being a maid?
She comes in.
I'm going to clean this house.
She really is passionate
about cleaning my house.
And she is therefore a
lot happier in doing so.
I get a beer at the local
brewery and the guy who's
pouring me the beer, I'm
asking him what his passion is.
He's like, beer.
And he's telling me
how beer is made,
and I learned more about
beer in that experience
than anything else.
So, it was weird,
though, because I'm
on this mission,
this quest, talking
to people about their passion.
And someone asked me,
what's your passion?
I was like-- I wasn't
prepared to answer.
It caught me by surprise.
So it's interesting,
because I reflected.
As a child, my passion
has always been fast cars.
So here I am, driving a
fast car around the country.
And ideally I have
this plan for myself
to continue to promote my
clothing line and perhaps
a new line based
upon this Pocket Man
emblem and the spirit of
it and everything else,
very similar to what Paul
Newman did, drive race cars.
But I'll get a team
of Polaris cars
and drive them
around the country.
The problem is
it's a motorcycle,
so it can't drive on car
tracks, and motorcycles
don't want to have it
on its track either.
I'm going to pause for
a second and take a sip.
And if anyone-- am I going too
fast, too slow, too boring, too
passionate?
AUDIENCE: The question is
around, explain your path
on how you incorporated
passion into your career.
SCOTT JORDAN: My career--
I was a nice Jewish kid,
and I was given two options,
be a doctor or a lawyer
or go into dad's business.
Dad happened to own a cemetery,
so I went into the cemetery
business, and I was knocking
doors door to door selling
cemetery lots in Cincinnati.
It's a hard way to make
a living at 21 years old,
not something I wanted to
do, but something I did.
And I was involved in
that for a couple years
and actually really
successful at it.
Not passionate about it.
Although you could be
passionate about it.
You're helping people plan.
But not something
you graduate college
and you're excited
about doing in my case.
So, sold the business
out from beneath me.
I didn't know what
to do with myself.
And I knew I had
to make a living,
and I knew I could make
a living as a lawyer,
so I became a lawyer.
And I knew very soon
in practicing law
that it wasn't
going to be for me.
So I was starting to
look for exit strategies.
In the problem is-- and
I think this happens
to so many people-- I was making
really good money at that age,
and even now looking back.
And you're just stuck.
To take that risk is
really, really, really hard
to walk away from that all.
Fortunately I
didn't have children
and I had a really
supportive wife.
And we kept looking
for things to do.
I tried to go into
biz dev roles,
but once you're a
lawyer, the whole world
looks at you as a lawyer.
You have like a scarlet
L on your forehead.
They really do.
I applied for jobs, and they're
like, but you're a lawyer.
And I've actually been
involved in some lawsuits
including with Scott USA when
I moved to Ketchum, Idaho.
They tried to force me to
change the name of my company
because they thought I moved
to confuse people into thinking
they were buying ski
poles from SCOTTeVEST.
Are you familiar with Scott USA?
They make bikes and ski poles.
So, I just did a lot
of soul searching,
and I had a really
supportive wife.
And I decided, if
I'm not going to be
able to get an opportunity
working for someone else,
I had to try it for myself.
So I was really
fixated on coming up
with the perfect idea,
an idea that no one
else has thought of.
And I came up with this
concept for wiring clothing
and patented it and thought
that that was the idea.
But it really wasn't
about the idea,
and it wasn't about the
patent despite all the stuff
on "Shark Tank," the arguments
about patents and stuff.
It was about building a
brand and being passionate
about it and execution.
You hear this so much.
It's who can execute better,
who can follow up better.
I mean, how many opportunities
are in your inbox
that you don't bring to
conclusion or try to maximize?
And that's a short answer.
There's a lot of
it in the book as
to how I made that transition.
There were some
dark, dark moments.
At the time, when
I couldn't decide
what to do because taking
that jump is the hardest jump,
and Hammacher placed an order.
And I thought it was going
to be-- Hammacher Schlemmer.
I'm a gadget guy.
And at the time, Hammacher
was the coolest thing around.
This was before the really real
evolution and all the consumer
electronics.
I don't even know-- cellphones
were just developing
and iPods weren't even around.
And I was actually
in my shrink's office
trying to figure out.
I'm at the lowest
level like, what am I
going to do when I grow up?
I'm 30-something years old.
I can't figure it out.
I got to support my wife.
And Hammacher, the
buyer from Hammacher
called while I was in
the shrink's office.
And I said, well, that's a sign.
Well, as it turned
out in that case,
the buyer said yes, he
wanted in and all the stores
and everything else.
And lo and behold, he wasn't
replying to my emails.
I'm like, uh oh.
I just now quit my job.
I stopped looking at
all these other paths.
And I then e-commerce enabled my
site kind of as an afterthought
and finally showed up at
Hammacher's office one day
and said, hey, what's up?
I got an order in China
and everything else,
and you going to come through?
He said, I hate
to tell you this.
Today is my last day.
Meet the apparel buyer.
And the apparel buyer
wasn't a gadget buyer,
and she's just like,
oh, it's just pockets.
I don't get it.
I don't carry these things.
So that fell through,
and then as a result
that door closed but
the other door opened.
And that was to this day
over 85% of our business
is direct to consumer.
It enables me to have a direct
relationship with the customer,
and it enables my
passion to come through.
I go around the country
and do these fan events.
I don't care if two, four
or 50 people show up.
I get an opportunity
to interact with them.
I'm not selling them anything.
I'm telling them
basically my story
without the slides, which I'm
pretty much doing right now.
So does that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it was very good.
SCOTT JORDAN: All right.
So, invite people
along for the ride.
So that's what I've done.
I open up my entire life.
You will not meet another
CEO in the entire world that
is more transparent and
engages with more people.
I've been crowdsourcing ideas
and concepts for awhile.
Again, look on Scott Jordan.
You'll see.
I'm asking people ideas.
I'm engaging with
people, and I'm
doing it in a truly
passionate and authentic way.
And guess what?
It comes through.
I'm wired so I cannot lie.
There's just something about me.
And I fundamentally
believe that 90% of people
can tell a little
white lie and not
think anything wrong with it.
Our company is founded on the
basis of honesty, integrity,
and transparency.
So when you meet me,
you get true passion.
You get true authenticity.
So I bring people
along for the ride.
And truly, I take
them in my car,
and I ask them
about their passion.
I'm truly taking them for
not just a metaphorical ride.
I'm taking them for a ride.
But I think Cliff's been
following me for a while,
and he can attest to it.
And so, yeah, it's
funner that way.
It's fun to do things
with more people.
And then they root for you.
They root for you.
They say, who's this
guy who quit his law job
and just reinvented pockets?
And even more absurd,
January 1 I declared
myself the pocket man.
And I'm creating this
insane, absurd superhero
based upon every
man's gadget guy.
And at CES I go to parties,
and everyone collectively
does this.
Pocket man!
And they get in front of
the car, and they yell.
It's something that
makes you smile,
so I'm inviting people
along on the ride.
And I find that passion
is infectious too,
because when people
are around me and when
I'm around other really
passionate people, you feel it.
You sense it.
You want it.
You want to do something.
And so what I've
had the opportunity
to do is ask what their
passion is and maybe give them
a kick in the butt and maybe
just, hey, you should do it.
I'm not going to preach
to them, but if I
can influence one
of 1,000 people
I talk to and 10 years from
now they're still doing it,
that's pretty cool.
I really enjoy that.
So, be willing to go far, but
make sure you go far enough.
It's just finishing things.
It's just once I
start something,
I just want to make
sure that I take it
to the furthest level possible.
And now there will
come times where
it just doesn't make sense
and it's time to stop.
Even just getting
in the Google store,
I wanted to be in
the Google store.
I knew it made sense.
It took a lot of back and
forth emails and begging.
And now it's here, and they're
doing really, really well,
and they want more, and
they're inviting me to speak.
And that's fricking--
I'm at Google speaking
for my very first speech ever.
So this is fun.
Embrace controversy.
As a small company with
no outside investors,
just my wife and I own 100% of
the stock, virtually no debt,
profitable since our
second year in business,
and with the
personality that I have
and with my legal background,
there are many times
that I'm faced with a
controversial issue.
For example, when I first
started the company,
the E in SCOTTeVEST looked
like an italicized E.
Remember E in E-Business
Solutions for IBM?
I get a letter from IBM.
Please stop using an
E that resembles--
they owned the italicized
E. So I had a choice.
I could fight it to what
end, or I could roll over,
or the third choice.
Fighting it never makes sense.
I would never incur.
But I said, OK.
I did a big press release.
David versus Goliath.
IBM's forcing me
to change this E.
I agreed to a
settlement agreement.
I will change the E
in all future runs,
but I'm not going to destroy
all my current garments.
But everything I have now, so,
I couldn't keep them in stock.
I sent an email out.
People from IBM,
I want the IBM E.
If you look at controversies--
and most people avoid them--
you're avoiding one
half of the situations
and one half of
the opportunities.
So you look at something
controversial and say,
how can I work that in my favor?
Now, again, I don't have
a board of directors.
I don't have a boss.
I have a personality that can
get away with these things.
But for me, it's work.
Same thing with Scott
USA when they sued me.
It's the world's
most expensive E.
I had to change the E to all
uppercase because SCOTTeVEST,
it was a lowercase E.
And they said, well, it
looks too much like Scott USA,
and so they made me change it.
And I write about
this in the book,
and the whole
argument with lawyers.
And I'm sitting there
with the lawyers
and in settlement, mandatory
negotiations in federal court.
And they said, OK,
what we're going
to allow you to do is continue
using the name SCOTTeVEST,
but you have to make
the E uppercase.
And I could have
continued fighting it,
and I just decided that
I would accept that.
But then they said,
well, and you also
have to pay us the
$100,000 in legal expenses
that we've incurred
to date fighting this.
And I was like, you
have got to be kidding.
And I said some really
colorful things to my lawyer.
And before I said them, I
said, you are my mouthpiece.
You were hired to
repeat everything I say.
You go in there, and you tell
them exactly these three words.
They're in the book.
I'm not proud of them,
but I wrote them down.
I'm not going to say them aloud.
And I'm not paying
their legal fees.
They had a choice of how to--
but I embraced the controversy,
and I got out there in my town,
little small town of Ketchum,
Idaho, with 5,000 people.
Everyone knew me, and I had
immediate underdog status.
Like, why is Scott
USA suing you?
I have no idea.
I made more friends, got
more notoriety from that,
and there's a lot
of other experiences
that if you do properly,
as I get larger,
as I get more well known,
it gets harder to do.
Because I have more to lose,
but I still have that edge.
And when Mark Cuban and
I got into the fight
on "Shark Tank" over
patents, I made it public.
I used my megaphone too.
Everyone is so wired to
run from controversy,
and I think there's
a lot of benefit
to embracing controversy.
This is actually
really interesting.
I have been able to meet the
most interesting key people
in this role, just so
many interesting people.
And my favorite one is actually
a very famous San Francisco
person, Amy Tan.
She placed an order
on our website,
and my wife, who is the
president of the company,
processes all the orders.
She goes through the order
and she says, wow, Amy Tan.
And she forwards
it to me, saying,
Scotty, I think
this is the Amy Tan.
She emails it to
me, and I forward it
to Amy, who I didn't know.
I'm embarrassed to say
I didn't read-- not so
embarrassed-- I
didn't read her books.
It's kind of not my genre.
And I forwarded it
to the email address.
I said, are you the Amy Tan?
And not with that inflection
but just, are you the Amy Tan?
And she writes back yes.
And as a result, I have had
just a tremendous relationship
with her because I treat her
like she's a normal person.
And I stay at her home.
I'm having dinner with
her tomorrow night.
And this goes on and on.
Thomas Hawk, who's done
most of the photography
you see here and with the books,
and a bunch of really, really
famous people that I encounter.
Steve Wozniak, he bought
something on my website.
Same way, Laura forwards it to
me, and I write back, thanks.
I'm a huge fan.
And speed is really
important to me too.
Rather than sitting there
and wondering what to say
and trying to pick the perfect
words, you just be authentic.
I think you can get away with
a lot more if you're quicker.
People can be a
lot more forgiving.
They like the fact that
you're really fast,
and that matches my personality.
So I write to him, thank
you very much for the order.
He was and is my idol.
And he writes back, oh, this
is an excellent accessory
for an iPod.
This was before
iPhones were out.
Can I use that on my
website, I write back?
Sure.
Within a day, on my
homepage, Steve Wozniak,
co-founder of Apple,
says, SCOTTeVEST
is an excellent accessory
for an iPad-- iPod.
Let me get the I's straight.
And as a result, we developed
this great friendship.
We shot a series of WOZ-isodes
together on green screen,
did all these fun things and
did all these photo shoots,
and I've gotten to see
him a lot of times.
So, when you're building a
brand like I was building
a brand, what I recognize
is the importance
of getting key influencers
and not treating them
like they're the
most special person.
They know that what
they've done is good,
but they want to be
treated like normal folks
and to have normal
relationships.
And to be very careful
as I publicized things,
because there was a point in
my life that I actually live
streamed me working constantly.
You have to be very careful
as to what you would reveal.
So, this is really hard for me.
I just thought everyone
was wired like me.
I had no mentor.
As a lawyer I had no training.
They just throw you
in there and say,
start dotting I's
and crossing T's.
And you report to a collection
of four or five partners,
and you gravitate
towards one or another.
And so after I started
Scott-- my biggest problem
in running the businesses
is people, managing people,
because it's hard.
Honestly when I was taking
an HR class at college--
I went to the Ohio
State University.
Go Buckeyes, champions--
I was like, why HR?
You pay people money.
They do their job.
There's a contract there.
As I've learned from
the way you guys
operate, you guys are amazing,
your HR practices, what you do.
I want to implement it.
It's compounded in my case.
I'm so passionate my passion
is often misunderstood.
I'm so visionary that
I'm constantly changing.
I'm thinking three years out,
and I don't have the time
to explain why I'm thinking
to every person at all times.
I live in a community
that has 5,000 people, all
there primarily
to ski or retire.
I don't have the applicant pool.
So I would hire
people and expect
that they would be looking at
Google Analytics every day.
How did the sale do?
And not everyone,
especially employees
that don't have that same stake
in that, are that passionate.
And that's OK.
I'm learning to accept that.
But what I'm also
learning to do is
try to put people in
jobs that have elements
that they can be
passionate about.
With as small a company
as ours with 15 employees
that basically has
to do just as much
as a company at Tommy
Bahama, from design
to supporting retail
stores and doing
retail stores and catalog.
We have a lot going
on, so that if you
are passionate about something,
I want you doing that.
Because you're going
to do it better.
You're going to have
more fun, and guess what?
You're going to be
more fun to work with.
Because at this
point, I don't have
to work another day in my life.
And I always wondered,
why do people
continue to keep working more?
Isn't it all about getting to
that number and then retiring?
And if you guys participated
in early stock options,
you are here because
you enjoy doing it.
So what I've learned is I want
to be around passionate people.
I want to be around
people who are excited.
But I think I set
a bar for passion.
I'm like an ever-ready
bunny on passion.
And that's OK.
So I'm always ready
to reinvent myself
when there's an opportunity.
I did it this year.
Who else would say, OK, on
January 1 I'm Pocket Man?
With all that goes
along with it, you know?
I got my own car.
I got my own logo.
I got my own theme
song, for god's sake.
Every superhero needs his
theme song, so says Kanye.
So I've done that several
times along the way.
And I think people get
bored, especially a brand.
But you have to have
consistent messaging as well.
We reinvented our company
and our logo several times.
It used to be SEV until we came
up with this pocket icon, which
speaks directly to our brand.
It's a tough brand to explain
to someone, especially
with a name, SCOTTeVEST.
The E, is that silent?
SCOTTe?
Scott Vest?
It's hard to pronounce.
So I think it's important,
whether in your job
or in your life or
your role, don't
be afraid to reinvent yourself.
I moved a lot when I was a kid.
And through all these moves,
I was born in Philadelphia,
moved to Cincinnati, went to
school all over Ohio, Columbus
and Case Western Law and
then moved to Chicago.
And now I live in Sun Valley.
And each time I move,
I get to start over.
But having started over,
the one consistency
is I'm still that
same passionate person
that I was in that old city.
I still can't lose that.
And I hope I never will.
And it was only when I
first really wrote the book
and really thought about
it and really said,
embrace that passion.
It's who I am.
Don't hide from it.
And encourage other
people to find it as well.
So, that's the last slide.
I want to take
lots of questions.
And there is a link.
You can download a
free copy of the book
at apparently tinyurl/pocketman.
I think that's a typo.
It couldn't really
be that, could it?
I have cards for that.
I will answer anything that
you have a question about
AUDIENCE: I feel
like from an outsider
perspective about
three, four years ago,
it looked like your business
hit a tipping point.
You had like, three
or four employees
and a handful of products.
And then suddenly you
seemed to explode,
and you were constantly
posting that you
were hiring for all
these positions.
And you had a women's
line, and now you're
up to 40 or something.
And I was wondering
if you perceive
that there was a tipping
point somewhere for you
somewhat recently.
And if so, what happened
around there that caused that?
SCOTT JORDAN: That's
a great question.
The answer is, about four
years ago or thereabouts,
historically we've been
doing this now since 2000.
So we were growing 20%, 40%, 50%
sometimes, but no more than 40%
a year for a number of years.
And then we started
doubling in growth.
And I freaked out, because
you hear all these stories
of the entrepreneur who
needs to step aside, let
a professional manager come
in and manage their business.
And when you have an
inventory-based business
with long lead times for
manufacturing cycles,
it's really complicated.
And so I actually, when we
started doubling in size,
I hired a lot of people.
And I hired a president, in
fact, a really big number.
And there were mistakes,
really bad hiring decisions.
And there was a lot of
activity that you saw online.
And I learned a tremendous
amount about management.
Had no corporate culture.
I went from three people to
21 people without saying,
what is it that's
important to SCOTTeVEST?
Not even from a court.
What does SCOTTeVEST mean?
What is our brand proposition?
And all those questions
that-- the problem
was when you grow too fast and
you're a slave to the growth,
you grow or die.
But be careful not
to die growing,
because that's what happens.
So fortunately we
had the wherewithal
to stop and slow down.
We let a lot of people go
or the attrition happened,
and we focused on-- it
sounds so obvious-- focused
on the fundamentals, and we
created a corporate goal.
But it's true.
And we focused on, the
primary goal for last year
was happy employees.
Well, actually it was
build brand, number one,
to make our brand
stand for something
and understand that
it stood for pockets
and the functionality of
pockets and the engineering.
And then make happy employees.
So as a result, we had
a bit of stagnation
after we doubled in
size in that one year.
And we've been now, without the
pressures of outside investors,
we've been slowly growing again.
And part of the
problem is that I
thought that all
the dot-coms that
came and went, all the VC
stuff, all the stuff you hear,
it's just like, the only
thing that's meaningful
is to grow to 100 million
and then go public.
And there are companies.
Bonobos is perfect example.
Are you familiar with Bonobos?
They have sold more stock
than they have clothing.
And they have a valuation
that probably is $500 million,
but they have not made
a single dime yet.
I have been focused
on profits and lately
happiness more so than profits,
because if you have happiness
the profits will come.
So I've never, though,
really experienced
the true Malcolm Gladwell sense
of the word tipping point.
And I always feel
like it should happen.
I don't get it.
I've got all these celebrities.
I come here.
I get exposed.
I'm in Google.
I'm in SkyMall, and I'm
in a major motion pictures
are showing, and Michael Mann
calling me up and saying,
you have great products.
And I'm in CES.
I tool around with TechCrunch.
And it just doesn't
happen that way.
There's not that explosion,
or it hasn't happened so far.
But you know what?
That's OK, because I'm
living a pretty good life.
I built the house of my
dreams on top of my business.
I live in Sun Valley,
which is gorgeous,
and I get to do pretty
much whatever I want
and call it work.
Did that kind of
answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT JORDAN: Thank you for
your business, by the way.
You've been a good
customer for many years.
How long?
AUDIENCE: I bought my first
jacket from you in 2005, 2006.
SCOTT JORDAN: Wow.
How'd you hear about us?
AUDIENCE: I was going on an
overseas trip to Germany,
and I was looking for a
sort of all-weather jacket
that was going to be
able to carry my stuff.
And I was in a store
and saw one of yours.
I don't even remember.
It was a travel store.
It was a sort of
a brown felt one.
You haven't sold it for years.
SCOTT JORDAN: Yeah, the Rodeo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and fell
in love with it, and--
SCOTT JORDAN: Was
it Edwards Luggage?
AUDIENCE: Pardon me?
SCOTT JORDAN:
Edwards Luggage here.
AUDIENCE: Possibly, yeah,
I think that's right.
SCOTT JORDAN: Yeah, one
of our few resellers.
AUDIENCE: And it
really worked out well.
That jacket was stolen
a little while ago.
SCOTT JORDAN: The
tough thing is--
AUDIENCE: It's been
replaced, of course.
SCOTT JORDAN: We've always
struggled with how do you
market a product that--
what do people search for?
Clothing with lots
of-- what do you
search for when
you want something
that you didn't know existed?
Clothing with lots
of clever pockets.
Not a lot of people
searching for that.
Travel Vest, we own Travel Vest.
You search Travel Vest.
Oh, and yeah, I
missed the important--
when we started doubling,
it was interesting.
We used to be highly
focused on gadgets.
It was a dark and
very masculine site,
and it was very gadget
oriented, a very male site.
And we sent out a
request to our customers
for pictures of themselves
wearing our products.
And we were overwhelmed.
Thousands of pictures came back,
and everyone was wearing it
at a location like
Great Wall of China.
I got more pictures of people
wearing the stuff at the Great
Wall of China than
any other place.
And I was like, wait, maybe
we don't make gadget clothing.
Because gadget people, if you're
in front of your computer,
you don't travel.
If you're not traveling,
you don't need pockets.
I mean, you need one
pocket but not a lot.
So we changed our
branding-- I forget.
It was like five years
ago-- to travel clothing,
and we came up with the tag line
"for the trip of your life."
Whether it's a trip
to the grocery store
or a trip to China, you need
a pocket to put your stuff in.
And as a result of
changing our branding
and in being inclusive,
incorporating our customer
base in a lot of the
photography in the catalogs,
our business doubled.
And then we went on that
slide of a ton of bad hires.
And now our branding is
more pocket focused, not
so much travel.
But it's more about the pockets.
AUDIENCE: Why not have a
license, like Gore-Tex?
SCOTT JORDAN: Well,
that's the premise.
That was the goal, licensed by
technology enabled clothing.
When I started, I
didn't want to sell
a single piece of clothing.
And this is the company I
pitched to "Shark Tank."
I couldn't mention the word
SCOTTeVEST because if I did,
I had to give the producers
5% of my business.
And yet they kept
asking for SCOTTeVEST.
But that, like Intel Inside.
AUDIENCE: Or Dolby
Digital, right?
SCOTT JORDAN: Yeah, exactly.
That was the premise.
But it's just clothing
companies don't
want to pay for the privilege
of putting a piece of Velcro
and controlling.
We have licensed
to VF Corporation,
which owns North Face, and
Ralph Lauren, and Under Armour.
Most of the major clothing
brands are licensees of ours
through litigation.
AUDIENCE: So what
are some challenges
you faced and lessons
you learned from starting
a business that was
not your expertise,
so going completely
from law into something
you had very limited
background in?
SCOTT JORDAN: God, I mean,
that's a loaded question.
A lot, everything.
What I've found is that
any expert I hired,
within a very short period
of time and doing a couple
Google searches--
thank you very much.
I appreciate it-- I
could learn almost as
much about their
expertise myself.
And oftentimes I found it was
easier to just do it myself
than rely on outside consultants
to do my work for me.
So I think the
challenge I still face
is when do I know I
have a good consultant
that I can rely on them
to do what I'm hiring them
to do and not have
to do it myself?
I still struggle with that.
I mean, I've hired several
PR firms along the way.
I hired these experts to get
me PR, and they cannot do it.
I fired one, probably fired my
fifth PR firm, maybe even more.
And I talk about this
a lot in the book,
and immediately
hired another one.
If you're watching,
please do a good job.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, when you quit law,
did you have a fallback plan
or a time limit as to, I'm going
to try this, if not go back
to law?
SCOTT JORDAN: No.
No, I really didn't.
I didn't think it through.
I thought that the worst case
scenario was I go bankrupt.
And in this country,
we're very fortunate.
It's the best country in
the world to do business.
You go bankrupt, who cares?
You start over.
I could always go back to law.
That was my fallback plan,
and it was a miserable one.
And every year, my law
license comes up for renewal.
And I'm like, oh, do I
want to pay the $250?
No, I'm ready.
I really think I don't
need a fallback plan.
And every year I still
send the damn check in.
My life's a lawyer too,
and she wouldn't do it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey Scott.
Just a quick question.
You mentioned Google
Analytics before.
SCOTT JORDAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us a little bit
about how you use that or
if that's been instrumental
in any of your success?
SCOTT JORDAN: It's a
love-hate situation.
There's so much--
AUDIENCE: What do you
love and what do you hate?
SCOTT JORDAN: I love
the amount of data
and I hate the amount of data.
I was a very early adopter.
We've been on Google Analytics
since the beginning of time.
And I love the fact
that within a second
I can see how things
are performing.
And as a result, it puts
a lot of pressure on me
because I know that
if I do something--
like I'm on this trip, and
my car has QR codes on it.
And who uses QR codes,
especially with a car
driving 70 miles an hour?
But I look at the Google
Analytics every day,
and it makes you a
slave to information.
I really wish that there were
better human beings involved
in my organization who can
condense the information
to give me actionable items.
I used to look at it
religiously daily, twice a day.
It was up.
I haven't looked at it in years.
I rely on my wife to tell me
if we're doing well or not.
And at the end of every day,
I say, how did we do today?
It was a good day,
bad day, no numbers.
We have never done a strategic
plan, never done any.
I don't review, just
keep trying to focus
on what I think is
the right thing,
and it's proved
pretty good for me.
AUDIENCE: Your background
is being a lawyer,
and you're not happy about it.
But it enabled you to
come up with the fund
to start this business now.
I came from Japan three years
ago because of the disaster,
and I pretty much had
to start from scratch
my life in the United States.
And I had a big dream.
And I am actually starting a
business, but the challenge
with raising the money.
And I got people who
invest, but the people
has a lot of fear
of losing the money.
And so I'm dealing with that.
And so I guess the question
is, if you weren't coming
from the background
of having money,
what would you have
done, and would you
choose people whose hard-earned
money and have a lot of fear
around it?
Is that a good investors?
What would you say in that case?
SCOTT JORDAN: So,
when I started--
this is a great
question-- I always
thought you started a business
with other people's money.
I just thought
that's what you did.
And I actually started
with a home equity loan.
It was $60,000 was
the seed money.
And at the time-- this was
before the real estate crash--
it was fairly easy to get
a home equity loan just
based on credit score, and that
wasn't a great deal of money
to start a business.
That is all the
capital I used to start
my business, effectively.
But to me, that was a lot
of money, to invest $60,000.
But I was prepared to
lose it, and if I lost it,
I guess I would have lost my
house, which would have sucked.
But I looked at all sorts
of different alternatives.
I looked to SBA loans.
I looked at having investors.
And in fact one guy who
sits on my advisory board
along with Steve Wozniak, who
is on my board of advisors,
which I'm proud to say.
One guy came in, and I said,
this is right after 9/11.
My business was doing horribly.
Everyone's was.
It's a luxury item.
You don't need a
SCOTTeVEST to travel,
which I'll tell a
related story to.
And he looked at my
books, and he said,
I don't think you
need investors.
I think you can do it, because
before 9/11 I was already
starting to be
cash flow positive.
And then after 9/11 with
the holidays coming up--
he convinced me.
And he stood to gain because
if he could have raised money
for me, he would
have gotten a piece,
and it would have been
profitable for him.
And he said, don't do it.
And it was the smartest
thing I ever did.
Because the time
and energy you will
spend keeping your investors up
to date and keeping them happy
and wondering when
their exit strategy is
and wondering why you
made this decision,
I'd much rather dedicate
that to the business.
So in my case, it
wasn't the money
that I made while practicing
law, because most of that
was spent on living
big in Chicago.
You don't save that
much money at that age,
as much as you should.
But having the luxury of a
wife working full time that
was completely supportive of
the idea, which was awesome.
I couldn't have
done it without her.
And to this day, all of my
success is because of her.
She is the hardest working
woman-- person-- in the world.
She gets to the office
every day at 12:30,
and she leaves the
next day at 4:00.
She puts in 16-hour days, and
she's there processing orders.
She's like a machine.
She just loves the
work, and she makes sure
that we don't make
mistakes and we
don't make bad hiring decisions.
It's hard, because you have to
have a home to borrow against.
But, you know,
what I would advise
you is find a
business that doesn't
require a lot of capital.
Service businesses,
websites, do something
that doesn't require
the capital investment.
Most businesses in America
are service businesses.
AUDIENCE: But what
about the passion?
I have this background
of writing a first book
on raw food diet for Japan, and
I became the raw food person
in Japan.
And since this
last three years, I
have just followed my other
passion, which is language.
But I really want to start this
juice bar, and I got the place,
and dealing with
this PG&E building,
which is huge company.
And they're just dragging
us along for six months now.
And I'm at the point I
don't know what to do now.
What can I do to make
this move faster?
What should I--
SCOTT JORDAN: Well,
if some things
are outside your control,
you can't blame yourself
for doing that path.
I'd find if there
are other places.
If you're really
passionate about that idea,
find a way to pursue it.
And if you need
investors to do it,
then find some
friends and family,
because they really
understand you.
But go into it
really passionate.
If you are going to
fail, there is no-- there
was no plan B for me.
There was none.
And I really, I painted myself
intentionally into a corner,
because I knew I had to succeed.
Because failure was not
a good option for me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Scott.
SCOTT JORDAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I just glanced
through the Amazon review
you mentioned.
I noticed there are entries
like a kind of wish list
of which you
mentioned in the book,
like a detail like
how you started
with finding manufacturing,
handling shipping, growing
customer business.
I want to take this opportunity
to satisfy those curious souls.
And it's kind of related to
that gentleman's question,
like how you're growing.
But instead of making it that
loaded question, maybe just
like when you get
that idea, you get
that home equity fund, how do
you start getting manufacturing
and actually start the business?
SCOTT JORDAN: I am
the only apparel
maker and maybe the only
manufacturer in the country
and maybe the world who has
been manufacturing in Asia
and has never been to
my factories, ever.
I don't know if I
should be proud of that,
but I'm still working with the
same factories I started with.
I have great
inspection companies.
I use Skype.
I use video.
I have great correspondence.
So I'm going to start there.
If you ask someone,
in my case once I
start telling people I wanted
to make something in China,
everyone knew someone
who knew someone
who knew someone who
made something in China,
and they could get you
there one way or another.
The problem was that everyone
along the way wants a cut.
Everyone's hand is out.
I mean, it's like old
school merchant business.
It really is.
So fortunately, one of
my factories, the one I'm
still working, one of my
major ones, 14 years straight.
And my factories have all
come out to Ketchum, Idaho.
It's like a two-day
trip to come out
to visit us instead of
me going out to them.
I'd like to change
that, because I
think I do need-- they're
an extension of my company.
So the answer is
just passionately
decide what the end game
is and work backwards.
You need a factory in China.
You need a place
for your juice bar.
What are the steps
it's going to take?
Where's the critical path?
I do everything that way.
And anything that is a
third party I do first,
because I know anything
that's out of mind control,
I want to start earlier.
It's critical path.
AUDIENCE: One of your
tenets was, a day of action
is better than a
week of thinking.
A lot of people I know, even in
Google, they have great ideas,
and they try to work
on them part time.
Obviously it sounds like
you went cold turkey,
the cold turkey route, where
you just said, hey, look.
I'm going to go full time.
I'm going to quit
my job, do X, Y, Z.
How do you think about
what you gain psychically
by making that full plunge
versus the advantages of having
a job and working
in your free time?
SCOTT JORDAN: I
think it's dramatic.
I mean, to say, I'm
jumping in full time.
I'm painting myself in a
corner-- the flip side of that
is people who go into a
business with an exit strategy.
I don't have an exit strategy.
I want to go in thinking what
today, tomorrow, next year
looks like.
But I don't want to worry about
when I'm going to sell out.
So I think it's really
important that if you are going
to make-- now, it doesn't
mean that you just come up
with an idea, and
you love the idea,
and before you do your research
you quit your great-paying job
at Google or wherever
you are, and you just
go off and running.
But you need to
know when to jump.
You need to know when
to take that first step.
And then you know what?
After you take that first
step, take another one.
Don't pause.
Keep going.
And that's what I did, because
I got affirmation along the way.
But not everyone--
when I told people--
I was making really
good money as a lawyer.
I told people, I'm
going to stop and form
this company called
SCOTTeVEST about pockets,
they thought I was crazy.
People fell in two camps.
They thought I was
brilliant or crazy.
There was no one in between.
No one was like, ah, well,
that might be a good idea.
And that's kind of been
the story of my life.
I kind of tend to be a little
controversial, I guess.
So I want to thank you guys.
This has been fun
for my first speech.
Did I do OK?
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
SCOTT JORDAN: Thank
you very much.